welcome
company of scholars like
delighted to introduce
my friend and neighbor Gary Tomlinson
whose work I'm eager to hear about
because we're very interested in music
but we don't speak about his work
socially in our neighborhood so he
Gary's the John Hay whitney professor of
music and of the humanities here at Yale
and he came from the University of
Pennsylvania he's a PhD graduate of UC
Berkeley from 1987 and the next year he
got a MacArthur Fellowship so you must
have written a smashing thesis Gary we
think that really it's that was
incorrect on your Wikipedia page so Gary
is the author of five alerted texts on
music and also the co-author of a
popular music appreciation book today
we're gonna hear about his current work
on the evolutionary emergence of music
among mankind and his lecture topic
today is 1 million years of music Gary
thank you thank you very much for all
coming out on this balmy spring
afternoon I said I said to my
undergraduates on on Monday at least
we're done with the snow and they said
don't jinx it
I hope they were right the the title
that you see on the screen in front of
you am i miked appropriately by the way
is everything ok
all right the title you see on the
screen in front of you is the title of a
book that will be coming out in the
coming months and I want to say two
things about this title number one there
were not 1 million years of music not of
human music to be sure the Rick Prum
just told me he's gonna do 150 million
years of music that's a different
musical story that I'll be telling today
there were not 1 million years of music
but the point of the title is to say
that unless we look back a long long way
in hominin evolution we're not going to
get any full picture of how it is that
music and music incapacities music in as
if term I'll use a lot music in
capacities came about and the second
thing about to say about this this title
is note the assertion in the subtitle
that that somehow talking
about 1 million years that is the
emergence of music in capacities could
in fact tell us something very general
about the emergence of human modernity
all told I'll have a little bit to say
about that later on in the talk it
certainly is a major theme toward the
end of the book but let's start with
something much much more recent let's
start with the end of the story that I
want to tell here is a wonderful cute
little artifact that was unearthed not
so very long ago this comes from the
Swabian yurov added that that region of
the the swabian alps to the southwest
portion of germany we're near the source
of the Danube River 70 in several
different caves over the last several
decades and in fact in some of the sites
even farther back but certainly over the
last few decades and a number of
different caves an arresting array of
artifacts have been unearthed this one
is one of the cutest one of the most
wonderful it's about this big it is
carved out of mammoth ivory it is the
figurine of a woolly mammoth it is one
of a series of figurines that come from
Fogel Herod cave in one of these sites
that I just mentioned there is a famous
horse there are several other mammoths
there are there is a feline figure there
is a bird there are several different
there's a whole array of these from from
folio Herod cave now the artifacts that
I'm going to show from this region of
near the the mouth near the source
rather of the Danube River these these
artifacts take us back to what our
archeologists think are the earliest
artifacts or some of the very earliest
artifacts made by Homo sapiens in in
Europe do we know for sure that they
were made by Homo sapiens we don't know
much of anything for sure about these
things but but it is almost almost
undoubted that they must be the product
of Homo sapiens all the behavior that we
know of the one other species that was
very prominent of hominins at this time
in this region that is to say Homo
neanderthalensis or the Neanderthals
suggest that they were not up to this
kind of handiwork though they were up to
some pretty significant and
sophisticated handiwork so from this
from another cave whole entire novel
from this same region comes the famous
lion mane of Hohenstein STOVL this is a
this is a statue
again of mammoth ivory it's about this
big it was first unearthed in 1939 in it
was not put together it was not even
seen to be a puzzle that needed to be
put together until some some
archaeologists looked at it some 30
years later and pieced it together into
this striking figure of a humanoid body
and and a feline feline head I'll talk
more about this a little bit later from
this same area of all of these of all of
these caves at the near the source of
the Danube come the earliest musical
artifacts that we have and I'm going to
show you a series of these now this is
this is a pipe from geison cluster Lee
another one of these sites it is made
from the the radius one of the wing
bones of a very large Swan this is a
fragmentary pipe fragment of a larger
piece it you can see that it has been
repaired and pieced together from a lot
of fragments in which it was found
note the the kind of the construction
that would have been involved the the
the bone would have been harder to start
with the ends of the bone were salt
sawed off and and then using a rasp of
some sort that working transversely
across the pipe the the the holes were
fashioned not by drilling into the pipe
but by scraping until until a hole to
the interior was opened thus giving it
that characteristic beveled effect that
you see on the finger holes here's from
also from guising cluster Lee from about
the same period is is a pipe made you
know in a very very different and more
complex fashion this now is made of
mammoth ivory and you can see you can
see a number of features of this in
order to make it a mammoth ivory they
had to cut longitudinally split open a
piece of ivory hollow it out on the
insides and then glue it back together
making finger holes in this case
probably with an awl drilled into the
into the ivory because the ivory
wouldn't break the way the Swan radius
might have you can see the seam running
off the side where up the side where it
was sealed again you can see the some
notches along the side that seemed to
have been made in order to help make the
seal a more airtight may be the adhesive
we don't know what adhesive was used
maybe some adhesive was was sticking
better when they made those notches the
little tag up at the top of course is
not part of the artifact that's
an archaeologists tag again made from
mammoth ivory in this case now in
nineteen in twenty thousand 2008 rather
some more artifacts started turning up
in in the the last of these these Danube
Valley sites that I want to talk briefly
about and and these are special for
several reasons that I don't get to in
just a moment
here's another apparently musical pipe
this one fragmentary still but for four
holes for holes well-preserved and
perhaps another hole down at the bottom
maybe another hole up at the top made
now from the radius of a Griffon vulture
this pipe from Halla fells interest in
2008 my Nicholas canard and his team he
is one of the lead researchers in this
whole area at this at this moment here's
another picture of it with a singularly
sinister vulture holding out his arm so
we can see just what bone was used and I
made sure that I had this right because
I thought Rick Prum might be here this
is it's not the bone that is highlighted
here it is this bone the top bone this
is the radius this is the ulna the ulna
also used in some other pipes for for in
some other archaeological artifacts as
well these hollow bones were very useful
for these musical pipes again showing
the clear effect of beveled finger holes
it also signals a mistake that
archaeologists often enough make one
might assume that oh my goodness think
of think they're there thinking ahead to
making airtight seals by beveling the
finger holes just the way we might in
you know in a in a modern recorder and
yet as I've already explained the
beveling is a necessary effect of the
way in which the finger holes were were
that were made into the interior a handy
serendipitous outcome perhaps for for
making the airtight seal but not
necessarily something that they had to
think about in advance this pipe was
found at jolla fells right alongside is
so close in such close proximity with
the next artifact I'm going to show you
that for one of the rare instances at
this historical depth the archaeologists
surmised that that the same people might
have been involved in making both of
these artifacts this is the so-called
venus of hohle fels
rather arresting Venus figure Venus
figures are famous from the Upper
Paleolithic period in Europe but all of
them except for this one are much much
younger and I'll talk about the age of
these of these artifacts just now in
fact the the all of these artifacts sit
at the far end of the reliability of
carbon-14 dating so it's been very very
hard to get very to get accurate dates
of these artifacts the problems have to
do with the short half-life of carbon-14
and the trace amounts that are there in
the first place that are then trying to
be measured six or seven half-lives back
it has to do also with the with the
calibration and they're changing amounts
of carbon dioxide in the atmosphere over
these periods that calibration curves
for carbon-14 dating are very very
difficult and and and controversial
things but the calibration curve now for
carbon-14 has been pushed farther than
it had been until recently and takes
archaeologists with confidence back well
beyond thirty thousand years and in some
cases almost 250 thousand years some
would argue almost 250 thousand years
these artifacts stand in carbon-14
dating now somewhere between 40 and 44
thousand years ago these are hugely
ancient artifacts in other words they're
they are very very very distant from us
they might be as little as five thousand
years after the final exodus of a couple
of lineages of homo sapiens came out of
africa to populate the rest of the world
in the first place that close to the
migration Out of Africa maybe only five
thousand years maybe more maybe ten or
fifteen but as little as five thousand
years they're hugely ancient artifacts
and to give you a sense of a
chronological span that we're talking
about here if we look at the next oldest
pipes that that archaeologists have come
across there's a whole series of pipes
some twenty one to twenty two pipes that
came from history's cave in in the
Pyrenees in the Basque region of
southern France the these pipes they
were unearthed early this one has a
dating 1914 there you can see another
dating 1939 they're the two halves were
not were excavated some decades apart
this series of pipes they date back
twenty to twenty-five thousand years
probably something on that order they
are they are in other words some twenty
thousand years younger
the pipe that we were just looking at
from hollow fells they there is one pipe
that is that his thought to be was
asserted to be by the archaeologists of
an older vintage and yet the
stratigraphy of the the excavation and
the similarity that was was not done
very precisely back in the 1930s and the
the similarity of design between that
pipe and all the others suggests that it
was not in fact chronologically
separated very far from them so those
are Easter it's pipes the next the next
oldest musical artifacts we have twenty
thousand years younger or so than the
pipe from hala fails or some famous
Paleolithic Paleolithic handiwork this
is the home of the famous Hall of the
Bulls from Glasgow in the Dordogne of
France central France you can see the
Oryx that dominates the scene with
horses superimposed over it and there's
a reindeer down at the bottom and some
characteristic abstract marks painted
around it that are very very frequent in
these Paleolithic paintings and very
enigmatic the Hall of the Bulls dates
back something like 17 or 17.5 or 18,000
years much much more recent once again
if we want to push back the history of
Paleolithic cave painting on the
monumental scale at Lascaux we can push
it back to broach Chauvet from the
eastern eastern portion of southern
france discovered only in the 1990s here
is the famous panel of horses from
chauvet some of you may have seen very
hot dogs movie the Cave of Forgotten
Dreams on a very romantic but quite
marvelous pictographic Lea cinematically
exploration of Sholay it Chauvet was
immediately closed it has never been
open to the public as soon as it was
discovered it was it was closed and
closed for archaeological study this
this panel of horses at first it was
asserted that it was thirty or thirty
two thousand years old which makes it
arresting the ancient as well the that
that dating has now been begun to be
revised down into the 20s
once again we're still ten thousand
years at least younger then
then those then those those artifacts
from Jolla fellows and if we want to go
back farther to artifacts that have some
sort of sense of usage about them that
is not utilitarian that is to say not
not just tools for scraping
cutting and so on and so forth we can do
that but in order to do that we need to
we need to head out of Africa
out of Europe and into africa in fact
and here is is the the poster child so
to speak for early so-called symbolic
behavior among Homo sapiens in Africa
some that word symbolic is a deeply
precious one in archeology these days
and and I try not to use it without
careful definition but it's usually
talked about as symbolic behavior here
it is from blombo's cave on the southern
coast of South Africa a piece of incised
ochre it's about four inches long about
this big the incisions have been studied
to a fare-thee-well they were made with
some sense of design involved in in
scraping them into this and there are
many other pieces that have been found
in blombo's cave now of similar
antiquity to this that have other in
size designs on them this was not in
other words the haphazard a product of
cutting some meat on top of a piece of
ochre or something like that
the this this piece dates back to more
than 70,000 years seventy to seventy
seven thousand years 73 years then is
the name that is usually that is the
number that is usually assigned to it
all right now all of this archaeological
evidence of music specifically those
pipes and so on that I've been showing
you all of this archaeological evidence
is the end of the story that I want to
tell and the question is how can we
describe the earlier stages we need to
come we need to make some general
statements first of all about music and
human or hominid evolution and and the
the three terms that I want that I will
highlight in these general statements
are first of all any such complex
behavior as as human or human music ink
needs to be thought of and its emergence
needs to be thought of in incremental
terms we need to take the behavior apart
into its into its into its component
parts and understand how and why those
components might have emerged rather
than taking music as a whole in trying
to say why didn't using emerge if you
read accounts of the origin of music of
which there are many these days in in
the
the literature some of it popular or
some of it some of it scholarly you will
see again and again the mistake made of
people trying to say well how did music
emerge it must have emerged because
people wanted to bond socially so they
started doing music or people wanted to
sing to their infants so they started
doing music these of course just begged
a whole lot of questions about how it is
the capacities for making music came to
the species in the first place why it is
those capacities that came no doubt for
non musical purposes coalesced into
musical practices all of those questions
are begged by the notion of taking music
as a whole as the as the object so we
need to have an incremental account we
need to have an a co-evolutionary
account coevolution I will talk about in
some detail in just in just a moment so
I'll come back to that and leave that
aside for the moment we need to we need
to have an account that involves culture
and by culture here I mean something
that can be defined very
straightforwardly and very simply I mean
the the notion of learned behaviors in
one generation that are then passed
along through mimesis teaching and
various other various other behaviors to
successive generations I don't mean more
than that by culture and with that
definition culture is a very very widely
dispersed phenomenon in the animal
kingdom if you read Michael Pollan's
recent article in The New Yorker you
might know that some people would say
culture is widely dispersed in the plant
kingdom I don't go there in fact but but
certainly it is widely dispersed in in
the animal kingdom so we need an account
that that in other words gives us an
incremental biocultural co-evolutionary
picture of how it is that that that
human music Inge took shape so first we
talk about some increments then what are
some of the increments what are some of
the basic capacities that are involved
in human in human music well some of
them are very ancient very wide spread
far beyond humans and and and and very
general in their application auditory
scene analysis as it is sometimes called
by people who study music cognition and
other sound cognition by the way
auditory scene analysis named in analogy
to visual scene analysis how is it that
our brain takes
a jumble of oral signals from from the
world all kinds of noises and other
things and separates them off into into
into distinct streams of sound right how
does our brain make sense of the
auditory scene around us how does it
distinct distinct oral streams is one
aspect of a distinct rhythmic pacings
would be another aspect of it distinct
acoustic amplitudes directionality from
which different sounds are coming all of
these are part of a very very general
generally dispersed auditory scene
analysis widely dispersed throughout
mammals to be sure and and and birds
also to be sure and some probably some
other some other animals as well in
probably lowering levels of complexity
but not necessarily so auditory scene
analysis is a very ancient and very
broad basis on which music ink might
happen hierarchic processing or
perception this is much less basic and
much less widely dispersed I think it is
arguable that that in certain forms
hierarchic cognition and processing is
very narrowly limited to a few clades in
in the in the animal kingdom by hara by
hierarchic processing I mean the
capacity to take to take stimuli from
the external world and process them in
such a way that they begin to nest
themselves a number of stimuli yet
nested in in in relation to fewer
stimuli retina stood in relation to
still fewer stimuli this is fundamental
to modern human linguistic capacities is
fundamental to modern musical capacities
in human music as well part of the
fundamental that one marker of the
fundamental aspect the fundamental
importance of hierarchic processing has
to do with perception of periodic
rhythms in in in human music in today by
which i mean rate rhythms coming a
stimuli aural stimuli coming at regular
at regular time intervals the capacity
of hominins to entrain themselves to to
regular stimuli from the environment is
an astonishing capacity astonishingly
astonishingly complex in fact it is
sometimes known by music cognitivist as
beat based processing referring to the
beats in metered music of course
this this perception of periodic rhythms
is not as widespread beyond humans in
the world today as we might think some
of you may have may have looked on
YouTube at snowball the the white
cockatoo dancing to the beastie boys
well maybe but aside from aside from a
few animals non-human animals in close
proximity that have been raised in close
proximity domesticated in various ways
and raised in proximity with humans it's
hard to find really clear examples of
the kind of beat based processing with
its hierarchic ordering of a regular
stimuli into larger groups larger groups
of those stimuli it's hard to find many
instances of this in the animal kingdom
so the perception periodic rhythms and
entrainment and beat based processing
all of these are related phenomena
tremendously basic to music and human
music in the sensitivity to pitch we
might think well isn't that the same
thing as the sensitivity to sound but of
course it is not humans managed to
distinguish for one reason or another
and it doesn't take music training to do
this it simply is something that we grow
into in our normal socialization in
ontogeny we distinguish those sounds
that come to us from the world that have
a fundamental frequency and then
overtones above that frequency ordered
in simple integer ratios two two one
three two three two two four two five
and so on we distinguish those from
other sound stimuli that come to us in
the world those things we give the name
pitch to whatever name we want to give
to it it doesn't matter the other things
sound like noise it is the difference
between oh and that's got an incredibly
chaotic array of overtones above the the
fundamental frequency when I when I and
and if you beat on a bass drum it's the
same thing but the pitch that I just
sang has an ordered array of overtones
or partials above its fundamental
frequency this capacity of our brain to
do this is a hugely mysterious capacity
it might have to do with neural networks
that are in which the neurons are
somehow firing in those precisely in
those ordered simple integer ratios but
if so we haven't been able to test this
and find this and locate this very
clearly yet the explanation for the
actual kind of neural explanation for
many of the things I'm talking about
today remain quite opaque and mysterious
but sensitivity to pitch
fundamental and from it by the way arise
the kinds of distinctions of Tambor that
we that we make use of in music all the
time
also in language but in a very different
way in language sensitivity to Tambor or
tone color has to do then not only with
the the the overtones above a frequency
but it has to do especially there are
several aspects to it has to do with the
onset of a sound the decay of the sound
all sorts of things but one of the most
important aspects has to do with the the
the different weighting of overtones
above a fundamental frequency so that if
a trumpet on a violin play the same
pitch the reason we hear one is
different from another has to do with
the differential weighting of the
partials above the fundamental frequency
that is played by both instruments
distinctions of Tambor Tambor by the way
in language is tremendously important
vocals in all human languages are
distinguished by it would by rather
discrete application of of different
Tambor's within individual languages the
perception of discrete pitch levels then
is only slightly is is a new is a
different kind of wrinkle that I'll talk
about more later on top of this
sensitivity sensitivity to pitch this
perception of discrete pitch levels or
intervals has to do with the fact that
once hominins at some point came to be
able to discern pitch and here it is
different from disordered noises in the
world they're set in at some point a
very general capacity to relate pitches
to one another in hierarchic modes of
one sort of one sort or another so
hierarchic cognition is involved here
again and this has to do for instance
with what in western musical parlance we
call octave equivalence a fundament a
pitch for the fundamental frequency here
and a pitch with a fundamental frequency
twice that fundamental frequency sound
incredibly closely related to human
listeners there's some evidence that
there are some other species macaque
monkeys certain birds but not other
birds also here this octave equivalents
and perceive it but it doesn't extend
hugely as far as experimental evidence
has shown us so far so octave
equivalence once you've got a sense of
this octave equivalence the the the
spectrum of pitch sounds that come it
can be broken up into smaller intervals
also related typically by small integer
ratios 3 to 2 4 to 5 6 to 5 and so on
these these smaller intervals in fact
give us the the scales that are used in
musics in musical systems all over the
world are they in any sense fixed no
they are not the the arrays they it is
it is pretty clear at this point that
musical systems tend to choose pitches
within the octave that gravitate towards
certain central points but these pitches
are marvelously malleable the
gravitation points are so to speak
attractors in in in a very very
interesting complex system but they
don't they are not they are not they are
not determinants and they are not in any
in any way fixed nonetheless once again
we here we see in this phenomenon of
discrete pitch the play of the play of
of simple integer ratios somehow
entering into our our perceptual
structure one of the basic lessons to
take away from this whole slide that
I've spent so long on is that there's no
such thing as simple music people you
long ago linguist long ago realized that
in natural human languages none of them
are simple they are all they are all
ordered in extraordinarily complex ways
and they and they require a complexity
of cognition that is essentially unknown
outside of beyond the human beyond
humans Homo sapiens in the world today
the the same is true of music there is
no such thing as simple music mother
humming a lullaby to to a nodding child
on the one hand a group of football fans
chanting chanting their team's chanted
at in a football stadium may be simpler
in many many ways than a mullerian
orchestra playing or than a gamelan a
30-piece gamelan band playing in in bali
yes it is simpler and yet all of those
phenomena have already crossed over a
bar of such huge cognitive complexity
that the differences between them are
insignificant compared to the difference
between musical and non-musical
ultimately okay
now I've just brought up the the
question of language and of course we
can't talk about the advent of human
music in without talking about the
advent of language as well the the an
incrementalist view which I think we
have to take into language just as well
as we have to take it to human music in
an incrementalist view is going to
suggest finally that that that these
that increments were reached reach back
in the increments of modern language and
the increments of modern human music and
reach back far before either music or
language existed these increments were
falling out in hominin behaviors and
capacities for a long long time in some
of the most general cases they reach
very far back but in the case is the
more specific cases that I'm talking
about here as I've said at the beginning
the last million years or so will get us
a long way in trying to understand how
they came about but these parallel these
parallel components these components
fell out in ways that are moving forward
through the evolution of hominins in
still distinct and separate ways and
finally perhaps overlapping in some ways
perhaps quite distinct from one another
in other ways but they are on there they
are developing at a moment when there is
no such thing as language and there is
no such thing as music right neither of
these exists for a long long time yet to
come so here's a very simple and very
bad use of PowerPoint chart that might
might show something like this in
schematic terms there you have a million
years back here you have a set of
capacities that are represented by the
arrows there you have on this left-hand
side you've got capacities that are that
that on the far side are more and more
specific to human music in today on the
right hand side capacities there are
more and more specific to language and
speaking today in the middle you got a
broad range of capacities that overlap
and that are used that are made use of
in both music and language but the point
is that the ages of these different
capacities are vastly different and
there is some moment of coalescence a
long moment of coalescence mind you but
a moment of coalescence that probably
happens in my estimation after 100,000
years ago when modern music and modern
language fall out they both coalesce out
of these sets of components that have
been developing for
long time now if we're gonna take this
incremental view it raises the question
immediately of the proto music and the
proto language that came before so what
can we surmise about the nature of this
proto music in this proto-language say
500,000 years ago a group of Homo
heidelbergensis at Boxgrove inning in
southern England trying to with a
complex social complex social
interactions they're scavenging a
hippopotamus skeleton the skeleton has
been unearthed the tools with which it
has been had was scavenged have been
unearthed and so on there they're
working hard they're working as a group
to fend off the hyenas that also want to
scavenge the the hippopotamus carcass
what kind of complex communicative
network can we imagine for this group we
can surmise a whole lot from first of
all what archaeologists tell us about
the social organization of these groups
and the social possibilities they they
they extrapolate this especially from
stone tool making a virus and the
techniques involved we can surmise a
whole lot from primate communication and
behavior in the world today we can look
to some other sources as well for for
our speculations they are speculations
of course but first we have to assert
that it is a complex communicative
network that was at stake here there is
no language there is no modern music in
but there is a complex communication at
stake it probably involved both innate
and learned vocalizations vocal gestures
and also bodily gestures these gestures
probably had the first the first burden
of carrying an effective charge from one
of these individuals to another
co-present individual so the emotional
charge was first and foremost in what
was expressed in all likelihood that
emotional charge aimed at manipulating
the other individuals around so that
they would do the things that the person
who was expressing these emotions wanted
done there probably were gestures and
even vocal gestures that pointed towards
towards in things in the world towards
other individuals and so on deictic
gestures as linguists tend to call such
things and the signals were almost
undoubtedly not discreet in the MA in
the manner of modern language I'll come
back to that discreteness later they
were rather it was it was a question of
analog signaling analog signaling
signals that especially in the
vocalizations
because discreteness comes easily to
bodily to bodily signals but it comes
less easily to to vocalize signals this
this analog signaling would would have
involved a graded spectrum of signals so
that so that uh-uh
means one thing ah means something else
ah means something else and yet the one
thing in something else is something
else I'm not clearly distinguished from
one another they simply are carrying
larger charges of effect larger
manipulative charges right so analog
signals the question then would be what
processes could transform this kind of
communication into modern music and
modern language and now we turn from
increments and incremental ISM to
coevolution and the nature of
coevolution and here's a very very basic
sketch of what I mean by coevolution in
the first place this is this is
fundamental in evolutionary thinking
today it certainly it reaches all the
way back it's very clearly signaled if
with a slightly different vocabulary
already in Darwin's On the Origin of
Species and here it is what I mean is
something very simple a feedback network
between organism and its environment and
the environment by the way including all
the other organisms in it whether of the
same species or of different species
you've got an environment that is a
selected terrain that is exerting some
kind of selective pressures on an
organism or a group of organisms or a
species and so on
you've got an organism or organisms or
species that are at the same time at the
same time altering the environment on
which they live in the course of their
life ways and what happens is is that
that the the and in the term that is
usually used the niche of this organism
is slightly altered by its own life life
ways of the species of the organism
whatever the niche is constructed by the
organism at the same time as the
organism is constructed across natural
selective timescales by by the impact of
selective pressures a changing
environment the changing environment
brought about in part by the organism
simple feedback a simple feedback model
seems to me is basic to the definition
of of coevolution this feedback by the
way once again the environment is amiss
environment not just the inert inorganic
environment this is in essence the
entangled bank with which Darwin
finished
very famously is on the Origin of
Species the once we start talking about
cultural animals however remember
animals that learn behavior in a
lifetime and then teach it or pass it
along somehow to successive generations
once we start talking about cultural
animals we get into bio cultural
coevolution which is a rather different
animal entirely and and here's here's a
slightly enhanced model of the feedback
network in this case part of the niche
constructive feedback to the to the to
the environment has to do with in fact
the cultural behaviors of the species
that is involved right those cultural
behaviors can be collections of
behaviors they can be even even rather
discreet collections of behaviors I call
these discrete collections of behaviors
archives cultural archives and and
hominins have for a very very long time
been been putting together cultural
archives that they then pass along to
successive generations these archives
have immense power to alter the selected
terrain more power MOT one might argue
than many other kinds of non cultural
behaviors that that animals might be up
to they're not more in all cases so
let's look at a simple example of a
cultural archive here is an ax shoe lien
hand ax from about 700,000 years ago a
by face rather symmetrical made from
from flint knapping or stone knapping of
one sort or another you chip down a P a
larger core until you until you get to
get to the shape shape something like
this this this a shoe lien technology
came in first about a 1.7 million years
ago it's immensely ancient and once it
settled in it became a cultural archive
of huge permanency and stability it
lasted for another million years before
in fact there were really significant
changes in the technological toolkit of
the hominids that are our ancestors and
other hominid species as well the the
the point about this as a cultural
archive is that there was a collection
of gestures that was needed in order to
be - in order to somewhat reliably come
out with something that had some
semblance of symmetry as the by face
that was that that was that was sought
that could be used as some sort of tool
this operational sequences
archaeologists tend to call it this
operational sequence is the cultural
archive as I'm envisioning it right it
is it is an archive of behaviors a
collection of behaviors that comes to
have some sort of coherency to it that
is then passed along from generation to
generation
all right things get then a little bit
more complicated because there's one
more wrinkle to this co-evolutionary
model as I see it as cultures begin to
sediment themselves as archives in
hominin in the hominin clade in
particular and I think it's arguable
that there's no other there's no other
group of animals in which this
phenomenon happened to anywhere near the
same extent but already early on by say
five hundred thousand years ago those
homo homo heidelbergensis cutting up the
hippopotamus carcass already early on
these cultural archives are coming to be
sedimented as i would put at getting
they're getting deeper and deeper in
their complexity the things that are
passed along the body of archives that
has now passed along from generation to
generation among hominins is getting
more and more complex and and and more
and more sophisticated as this happens
there is there is the possibility of
something new I call this something new
a cultural epicycle so here is now
epicyclic biocultural coevolution you've
got the same the same kind of feedback
model is is at stake here
you've got cultural archives that are
that are that are that are taking a part
in the nichkhun that are taking a major
part in the niche construction but at
the same time every once in a while you
have these a falling out of a rather
systematic array of cultural behaviors a
systematic array that for various
reasons takes on its own its own
systematization its own formalization
its own ways of moving somehow that
comes almost to have a life of its own
not as a living thing of course but as a
collection of behaviors and once it does
this it extracts itself ever so slightly
from the feedback cycle it becomes us
and what I'm calling again an epicycle
it it becomes a set of behaviors that
that in its own formality and its own
formalization has now has now come to
too
carry its own complexity and generate
its own complexity and once it does that
it can then feed forward into the the
main feedback cycle of the
co-evolutionary feedback cycle a
feed-forward element the only difference
between a feed-forward element and a
feedback element is the Independence of
the feed-forward element from the
feedback mechanism and it seems to me
that what is happening in crucially over
the last say five hundred thousand years
ago that differentiates hominin
evolution from every other kind of
evolution that had happened in the world
before is the proliferation of these
these formalized epicycles of cultural
behavior that then take on a role as a
feed-forward element in in the the
larger flux of feedback so let me give
you two examples one musical one not of
these epicycles by the way I don't draw
the line in any very firm way as to what
we want to call an epicycle and what we
might want to call a slightly looser
array of comfortable behaviors could we
call the eschew lien hand-axe set of
behaviors in epicycle sure why not it
certainly came to have something of an
independent life of its own as it was
taught again and again and again through
tens of thousands of generations of
hominins not in one species but in many
different species think of that a
technology that extends across many
different species lasts for over in a
million years in a very stable form and
yet is a cultural attainment that is
taught again and again and again a
cultural attainment of course based on
fundamental innate capacities of various
sorts but nonetheless a cultural
attainment so here are a couple of other
examples of more clear examples it seems
to me of what of what I mean by this
epicycle here is the here is the bead
making epicycle for instance now bead
making by which archaeologists mean any
little object that a hole is drilled in
so that it might be hung on hair it
might be hung on clothing it might be
hung on a string to make it make a
necklace or a bracelet or something bead
making is hugely ancient it the earliest
instances we know are about a hundred
thousand years old it is very widely
dispersed in fact so widely dispersed
that we cannot believe that that in fact
this was a matter of one group of
hominins teaching another group of
hominids how to make beads in some cases
that no doubt happened but in many other
cases it seems to have popped up
independently from in in various
so how did it happen well here's one
model of how this epicycle might have
taken shape you in a situation of
growing social complexity a situation in
which that we can see from the
technologies and the burgeoning
technologies of these groups say a
hundred thousand years ago we're not
talking about Homo sapiens Homo sapiens
the advent of Homo sapiens has now
placed something like two hundred
thousand years ago but the the in in a
situation of growing social complexity
they're part of that social complexity
might well have been the the realization
of different kinds of alliances within
the group they might have had to do with
kinship they might have had to do with
aspects of invisible statuses that were
that were involved that certain that
accrued to certain members of the group
ranks and so on the chief of the group
and so on this is an expression clearly
of hierarchic ignition once this kind of
sociality sets in hierarchical cognition
is long sense since present in hominins
Neanderthal toolmaking shows very clear
instances of hierarchical organization
but under the influence of this new
appearance so to speak of invisible
aspects of culture rank within a group
for instance under the appearance of
this in the in the the presence of all
kinds of skilled material workmanship
what could be more natural than that
small objects would be taken to decorate
bodies with and to mark so to speak the
otherwise invisible status of
individuals what could be more natural
than that there might be a proliferation
in many different hominin groups
including Neanderthals right perhaps
though bead making among Neanderthals
still remains somewhat controversial but
certainly many different Homo sapiens
groups what could be more natural then
than that there would be not just a
proliferation of this epicycle this
particular bead making out a cycle but
in fact a repeating of the springing up
of the epicycle in very different
far-flung places and by the way with
very far-flung materials it can be
seashells as you see here it can be it
can be minerals in some cases it can
certainly be bones and teeth they're
very frequently used it can be ostrich
shells which are very frequently used in
in northern and western and eastern
Africa and so on alright a simple
example of a cultural epicycle here's a
more complex example the case of
discrete pitch and then I will then I
will conclude I'm loading you up with
all kinds of things here and I hope
there will be there will be some some
questions afterwards a more complex
epicycle in this situation of increasing
social complexity we have a situation
necessarily of increasing communicative
communicative complexity the community
the vocal gestures that I talked about
in proto language and proto music are
now are now proliferating they're
getting more and more frequent they're
getting more and more elaborate perhaps
the the we couldn't imagine easily
enough a sharpening distinction of
international elements that would be
used in making some of these signals but
if you take an analogue graded spectrum
and you start making sharper and sharper
distinctions you come up with a problem
because the closest things are on that
analog spectrum the less you can
different less easily you can
differentiate them the signals are not
working any longer there would be a
pressure at some point for a
discretizing I'm making discrete of in
fact the graded analog spectrum I think
exactly what happened in in the case of
animals that were already preceding
pitch and perceiving it differently from
the noises of the world the percussive
noises of the sort that I the that I
just exemplified I think what happened
was it was precisely in these animals
that were already hearing pitch pitch
came to be a more and more discrete
element along these analog signals but
something interesting at this point
happened to divide between the overall
contours the international contours of
utterances that we still use to express
ourselves today in language and in music
overall melodic contours overall
contours to speech phrases and so on the
prosody as linguists call it of speech
that never went away that ancient that
very very ancient part of a proto
language and proto music and that was
one of the older components it never
went away but what happened was that
pitches individual pitches came to be
abstracted from that at that effective
signaling and once they came to be
abstracted the systematizing of pitch
arrays that I talked about before
octaves and small
intervals within the octaves began to
fall out according to the capacities
that depended on small integer ratios
for hearing pitch in the first place you
get a cultural epicycle that is pushing
towards an abstraction of discrete pitch
from the general melodic contours that
are still a very very powerful element
of communication both Protomen usable
communication and proto linguistic
communication what happens then we can
easily imagine in in in Medina socially
effective uses then for these pitches
and I'll talk about some of those uses
in just a moment but I want to emphasize
once more this new this new distinction
that has come about between general
melodic contours and discrete pitches
this is a distinction that is very
operative in human music today it is a
distinction that is operative in a
rather different way in human language
especially tonal languages which have
international structures large
international structures across phrases
but also have some discreet tones that
are used of course to convey meaning as
well
the epicycle are then of discrete pitch
all right so the coalescing then of
human modernity say one hundred and
twenty to sixty thousand years ago it
seems to me that it involves
fundamentally this abstraction of
thought and cognition and this
abstraction of thought and cognition is
falling out at the same time in the
conversion so to speak of proto
proto-language into modern language of
proto music into modern music of social
practices that are now taking on
increased complexity with invisible
realms attached to them ranks and
statuses and other sorts of kinds of
organization new complexities recognized
in kinship organization one the argument
has recently been made that that
somewhere with somewhere back from 40 to
80 thousand years ago would have been a
time when when kinship systems of the
sort that humans universally recognized
today in their societies of a huge array
of sorts that the university recognized
would have come into focus for the first
time
whatever we take and we take out of
these specific arguments what is
happening here in the most general sense
is what anthropologist Morris Block
calls the appearance of the
transcendental social block talks about
the transactional social
co-present individuals working out
transactions so as to so as to get what
they want in in the social organization
of which they're a part these are hugely
dispersed in non-human animals in the
world today and very very complicated in
non-human animals in the world today it
is arguable that at least beyond certain
very rudimentary levels the invisible
realms of social organization are unique
to humans in the world today and that is
that what what block refers to as the
transcendental social so the burgeoning
of transcendental sociality then
involves for instance language language
pragmatics that is to say a discourse
that was proto linguistic and is turning
into a modern language that is
nonetheless
in which there are certain kinds of
orderings of exchanges and so on and so
forth taking on the much broader and
much much more predictable ordering of
modern human linguistic discourse a
movement from what from language
pragmatics what linguists call
pragmatics to what Michael silverstein
another linguistic anthropologist has
called meta pragmatics meta pragmatics
would have appeared musical capacities
musical capacity is now falling out in
terms of organized performative
circumstances in which these capacities
would be called upon and once we get to
organise performative circumcircle
stances to performances in other words
we're talking about something that comes
very very close to the notion of ritual
in its modern and absolutely ubiquitous
human guise we're talking about in all
of this about offline sociality not in
other words I can react and communicate
up with my Co present individuals about
the saber-tooth cat that is threatening
us but we can sit around a campfire
thinking about how lucky we were to have
escaped the saber-tooth cat that
threatened us earlier today offline
sociality offline communication with all
of this this disappearance of the
transcendental social come imaginary
realms come minimal counter intuitions
as this little statue is called it is
counter intuitive because it puts a
humanoid body with a with a feline a
feline head and yet it's minimally
counterintuitive
because both the feline and the human
are very very very very very very
familiar what we see across this period
in other words from say seventy-five
thousand years ago to forty thousand
years ago is it seems to me the move
from that as as some sort of proto
symbolic behavior in the world to this
as as a full-fledged sense of a ritual
transcendency about human existence that
can be expressed in language in music
and in ritual behavior of all sorts and
in sociality in general so so what was
going on in Halle Fells 40,000 years ago
well I think probably something very
similar to what was going on at Chauvet
maybe thirty thousand years ago that's
the the famous panel of the of the the
felines or cats or something very
similar to what was going on under the
ten thousand or so years closer to us at
Lascaux or Altamira here's one of the
famous Bisons of Altamira same age more
or less as the paintings at Lascaux that
I showed you earlier or now we now we
see that these these these expressive
realms of humanity have taken on
monumental proportions right in the
paintings of Altamira or Lascaux and
those monumental proportions are it
seems to me stand in a direct line to
this next place where something similar
was going on gobekli tepe a certain
about twelve thousand years ago in
southeastern Turkey that's been a it's
been excavated only over the last twenty
years it is an astonishingly early huge
ritual center we don't know what it is
and yet it took a technology that we
wouldn't have imagined any hunter group
hunter-gatherer group at the end of the
Paleolithic and beginning of the Neal
that they had the capacity to do it it
built these huge stones stelae with or
pillars with with scorpions and birds
carved all over them there were many of
these these these complexes there seems
to have been nothing but a
hunter-gatherer society around as far as
archaeologists can tell this gobekli
tepe is a complete mystery unless you
see it in the line that I have been
tracing back straight back through from
the early Neolithic all the way back
through the middle of the the Upper
Paleolithic line all the way back indeed
to the African middle Paleolithic or
middle Stone Age as it is called and if
we take that straight line that
continuous
development we see that that what's
going on at Chauvet and Lesko and
Altamira and gobekli tepe is in fact not
so different from what's going on in
Jogja China these were for some time
claimed to be the earliest musical
instruments they are something like
maybe five hundred years old they are
carved with a with with the technology
they are made constructed with a
technology that is in fact now almost
40,000 years old
among humans by the time these things
are made almost 40,000 years old at
eight thousand five hundred years ago
they are made by making holes in hollow
bird bone flutes in this case in bird
bird bones rather in this case the the
bones of red-crowned cranes so in all of
this continuity that I'm pushing here
what we get is an alternative to the old
revolutionary views about how human
modernity came about the sapient
revolution 200,000 years ago then it was
a little different well the more we
learned about Neanderthals the more we
learned that they were extremely complex
creatures and and with its doing
extremely complicated things those
things are badly preserved and hard for
us to discern and there are a whole lot
of fights and arguments about them among
among archaeologists but there's no
question there they're very complex the
more we learn about the ancestors of
Homo sapiens in Africa the more we see
them up to very great complexities as
well the so the sapient revolution
begins to fade a little bit the Upper
Paleolithic revolution around 40,000
years ago in Europe certainly faded a
long time ago there are those who want
to transpose it into Africa I'd say
60,000 years ago but I think even there
there's a more gradual escola lessons of
forces that is involved rather than some
revolutionary change the Neolithic
Revolution
well the continuities between the the
monumental structures of the pyramids
and then another 8,000 years back the
gobekli tepe and another only 6,000
years back or 5500 years back Lesko and
Altamira those continuities suggest that
the Neolithic Revolution has been overly
overly marked off it has to do with
agriculture and sedentism and so on but
we learn more and more that the
domestication of crops and animals was a
gradual incremental development - it
didn't just start at the at the at the
beginning of the Neolithic we learned
more and more this
magnetism existed that is to say
sedentary settlements existed long
before the beginning of the Neolithic
there are there are very stable and
quite permanent villages on the Ukraine
on the Ukraine steppes made out of
mammoth tusks and mammoth jaw bones at
18,000 years ago now these people were
hunter-gatherers they were hunting
mammoths clearly from the building
consider materials they used but they
were still building stable structures
and long lasting structures and
structures that were absolutely
immovable so all of these boundaries
begin to all of these clear boundaries
that people want to paint begin to begin
to fade the axial age of the first in
the first millennium before Christ is
another of them that I that I think is a
highly dubious set of judgments about
about novelties supposed novelties at
the time revolutionary novelties at the
time instead we get the gradual
appearance of modernity gradual
appearance and not just a cross not just
for Homo sapiens but across several
species we get the coalescence of these
these features of modernity for how
probably finally in a small population
of humans around sixty or seventy
thousand years ago in East Africa a
population of humans that then that then
populated not only the non African world
but as genetic studies are more and more
clearly showing moved back into Africa
and populated the African world they're
making meeting there with Homo sapiens
groups some of which had been separated
from them for tens of thousands of years
and meeting up with them again and
interbreeding with them and and it seems
to me that if there is a coalescence if
there is some one moment at which this
coalescence happens it needs to be a
tremendously ancient one it needs to be
a long moment and it probably is is
located in this small population but
once the population begins to spread in
different places it meets up with
populations that are already burgeoning
with their own epicycles and these
epicycles merge with one another in
various ways these cultural forces merge
with weather
one another we get a whole very very
complicated history that is being traced
out now of climate change of population
migrations of the homogeneous Asians of
populations and genetic homogeneous as
well modernisations as well and we get
this repetition and proliferation of
epicycles and from all of this it seems
to me we begin to construct something
when we look back that is an immense
continuity
of traceable in gradualist terms across
the longest superiors much longer
appears than we have tended to imagine
and bringing about through this
epicyclic kind of coevolution the shared
modernity of all humans in the world
today thank you very much for listening
to all my words thank you very much and
gary has already invited questions so
let's hear from the audience
Oh with that question not heard how do
you define an epicycle is there is there
some necessary and sufficient set of
conditions that would allow one to
define an epicycle and i already said
that there's not in my view that is we
might see we might see something like
like the eschew lien hand acts as a
cultural epicycle though if so it seems
to me the loosest of sort as sorts and
epicycle of the loosens of sorts I will
say this in the most powerful of these
epicyclic formations there is there is a
kind of a kind of to use a word that is
used altogether too much these days but
which some of us are using in a seminar
right now to try and figure out there is
a kind of emergent complexity that comes
about that is a very very special sort
of thing it has to do with whatever the
elements are that that behavioral
elements acoustical elements in the case
of music and language and so on other
kinds of elements material interactions
with the world in a particular
circumstance but out of that certain
conjurer's of elements sometimes
something very formalized can come fall
Terrence deacon has a long argue
argument about about symbolic behavior
he defines symbolism and the advent of
human language much more carefully than
most archaeologists who want to talk
about it his book the symbolic species
from 1992 was a very very important one
it seems to me what he sees for instance
in in as a crucial moment of the
coalescence of language would be for me
another epicycle that is he sees a
moment at which signs of certain sorts
are coming to be indexical signs as
charles sanders peirce would call them
pointing science signs that indicate
things deictic science as I was saying
before those signs are coming to
proliferate so much in human
communication that at a certain moment
the even even the the the necessity to
remember the science is such that there
is a phase transition of sorts into a
set of signs that are self referential
and come to have their meaning because
of the nature of the set itself that
defines for purse it defines in some
crucial ways what he means by a symbol
many for many so Syrian linguists and
many other linguists it defines what how
language works in a fundamental way for
deacon he argues that that that that
would be a very very important moment
yeah I think he over plays how important
it was in hominin evolution he sees
language he's a linguist centrist he
seems language is absolutely central to
everything nonetheless I think he's on
the right track and I think that I think
that that that that is a great example
of a very careful of a very clearly
formalized epicycle necessary and
sufficient condition is no I don't have
them but something similar I think is
happening in discrete pitch whereby the
the acoustical small integer relations
the winnowing down of graded of graded
analog signalling systems into into
discrete elements falls into a kind of
processing that then makes a part of our
expressive vocabulary the the the
production of discrete pitch so I can't
formalize this epicycle but I know it
when I see it now no I don't know no I
don't I don't I don't mean that I think
I think I think in fact the attempt
actually to formalize it and make the
boundaries that you're asking for is
something I don't want to do I want to
see a graded move towards more and more
complex burgeoning x' of these cultural
systems all right something like that
please so what the difference is like a
discrete pitch 200
I think this is this is hugely it is the
center of homo of Homo sapiens sapiens
archeology right now trying to figure
out what happened to be between say it's
something I don't know 175 to 200
thousand years ago is what the genetic
evidence points to as the advent of homo
sapiens
well how reliable that is in the first
place is one question and I'm not
equipped to make a judgement on that but
something on the order of that let's say
let's just take us for to try and answer
your question the distance between that
and the appearance of distinctly modern
human behaviors in terms of technologies
and bead making and other sorts of
things the stuff at blombo's cave by the
way the difference between the
chronological distance between that that
genetic coalescing of something and and
the coalescing and the dispersion then
of these these remarkably different
behaviors is huge and nobody has a good
explanation of it I think that what my
explanation would have again to do with
with the proliferation the gradual at
first accretion of more and more complex
cultural formations epicyclic cultural
formations and in a certain point a
tipping point being reached whereby
these epicycles are proliferating and
hugely rapidly because of the very
complexity of communication of sociality
and and and the end of the brains of
these of these individuals themselves so
i think there's a big difference there's
a big difference in behavior between
Homo sapiens at 70,000 years ago and
Homo sapiens at 170,000 years ago
but I don't think that we have to look
for a huge difference genetically in
order to explain that difference that
huge difference in behavior doesn't have
to be a huge difference genetically we
don't need to look for magic bullets the
language mutation fox p2 genes and so on
and so forth we can explain it through
the a different set of means that are a
part of this complex web of biocultural
coevolution all right yes please
yep sorry on the lower left
oh sorry yeah no this is extraordinary
this is not random I didn't say this was
random they're there they're doing
something extraordinary with geometrical
geometrical arrangements and by the way
paleo the Paleolithic caves are and on
some very very old rock shelters in
Africa and so on the dating of which is
immensely difficult these things are
filled with geometric figures of various
sorts one interesting place where you if
you want to find a client kind of
cockamamie but very interesting
speculation about size geometrical
figures read a book called the mind in
the cave by David Lewis Williams Lewis
Williams is the last name the mind in
the cave it's a good read and and he
makes it he makes some really good
attempts at trying to deal with these
geometrical figures yeah yeah other
questions please
are you okay can I beat Chomsky on his
own terms that's the center question no
no no the court the question has to do
first of all there was that there was an
assertion in the question that it seems
to me that you're working against
formalization and I'm not in fact I'm
working
absolutely absolutely yeah yeah but
isn't the real kind of I don't know I
want to call it a kind of ethical thrust
of your argument to argue that our
inclination to look for formal formal
features as has the kind of essence of
music is
Auri okay okay the I put in pushing back
I think I'm understanding the question
but I'm not yet sure in pushing
backwards the question of formal
formalization of culture am I am I am i
denying a chomskyan position that would
say well I'm gonna give you the formal
structure as say in the brain that from
which it all comes indeed I am
I don't freeze ins that you you asked me
also about about experimental
possibilities there there are plenty of
experiments being done these days in
music cognition that point in all kinds
of interesting directions none of them
point in my reading of them point away
from the kind of development that I'm
talking about that I've talked about
today but I would say in regard to
chomskyan and post Chomsky and
approaches let's just take post Chomsky
and approaches the language right those
approaches have reached largely a dead
end in my view there there are some of
them that are much more supple and
subtle than others in terms of the
evolution of language but there are
others that simply throw up their hands
and Chomsky famously threw up his hands
and said we can't explain through
natural selective means how language
came about well Steven Pinker and Paul
bloom from from Yale then in 1991 and
1992 put out a wonderful article that
laid out the ways in which we could
think of natural selection as bringing
about the complexities of cognition and
production and so on that are necessary
for language to happen that was a
watershed argument against Chomsky in
mysticism ultimately as which is what it
the evolution of language had come to
seem in some ways it was an argument
against that but it wasn't a sufficient
argument in my view I think I think that
that that the bloom and Pinker argument
and especially then the Pinker argument
in the language instinct or how the mind
works those later books the bloom and
Pinker argument is one that that does
not it is linguist centric in the first
place it does not take account of huge
complexities of behavior and technology
and everything else that happened among
hominins long before language could have
existed it does not then take account of
the generative complexity of sociality
and culture itself what's happening
between bodies as opposed to just in the
brain and those things in the model that
I've laid out here are tremendously
important as forces in the
co-evolutionary cycles that I've been
talking about so is there an experiment
we'll do
want to prove this I don't want to prove
it I want to argue it as capably as I
can I don't think we're anywhere near
proof about any of these huge mysteries
about how we came to be the creatures we
are in the world today but I think one
can argue more effectively with this
model that reaches out to the place
space between bodies and works hard at
those cultural dynamics we can explain
better with that than with a model that
is that is centered in the brain
ultimately now that's not to say by the
way I don't mean to say for a minute
that the model that what's going on in
the brain is not crucially important it
is but if you don't have a brain that is
that is that is forming itself through
natural selective time periods in the
midst of this complex sociality I don't
see how you're going to get anywhere
near what we are today so that's the
that's the way something like the way I
would answer the questions that I think
you asked I want to say - so the
question the question is is there room
in my in my in my evolutionary view for
punctuated equilibrium for the popping
up for four periods of stasis that are
then followed by a huge leap in in in
evolutionary change absolutely there is
room in it and not only that it models
in cultural terms how such a thing would
happen
these epicycles are all about punctuated
equilibrium they're all about things
forming that suddenly kick off new
cultural and biocultural possibilities
so number one that it seems to me is the
case the only other thing I'd say an
answer the question is that it's always
talked about as goals punctuated
equilibrium read on the Origin of
Species Darwin lays it out right there
he saw that punctuated equilibrium was
possible and it lays it right out I
don't know why Gould laid claim to it he
gave it a name so everybody gives it to
him but but it dates all the way back to
on the Origin of Species by the way or
just a just a little you know don't read
my book leave my book aside but when it
comes out read on the Origin of Species
if you haven't it is one of the most
miraculous books
thought experiments that is ever that
has ever been produced and he sees so
much that is still basic he sees
co-evolutionary complexity he sees the
complexity of behaviors and how they
would develop in cultures the case of
the case in point being the the beehive
and how it might have come about he sees
punctuated equilibrium he sees a huge
amount all the while having not the
slightest idea how inherited variation
could have come about it was all a black
box to him and yet everything around the
black box was so clear so miraculously
clear what a book yes
how are you bring all this to bear
musicology and what mistakes about the
day so the question is the first part of
the question is about remind me sorry
Musa King what I mean what do I mean by
music Inge thank you very much Martin
for that yeah anybody want to step up
from the music department of the back
there and leap into this so that's the
first question the second question they
can also step up in the back and leap
into the question of musicology wherein
musicology might might this discourse
subsist well this discourse first of all
is is is a step aside from the kind of
musicology that I have spent most of my
career doing it's a step to a different
terrain but I don't think I don't think
it is a step that that simply breaks its
ties to musicology I think that what
what the humanity has had done over the
last 50 or 60 years is continually and
very productively theorize and come to
understand human difference all the
while they call themselves the
humanities and they recognized that
there was some foundational sameness
there that they were not talking about
it is time for the humanities to take
take hold of the conversation about
foundational sameness that that make us
all human in ways that are more than the
platitudes about what it means to be
human that's
you know that's what I don't know
listening to Beethoven is an affirmation
of what it means to be human
well I think that actually I feel that
very strongly and yet it doesn't tell me
much specifically about what it means to
be human
so the humanities have been the
humanities of difference tremendously
productively they now need to be both
the humanities of difference in the
humanities of human sameness and and I
think I think every humanistic
discipline needs to be thinking about
this if we don't think about it there
are cognitive scientists and a whole
bunch of other people out there many of
whom are my good friends who want to
think about it and they simply don't
have the training in the in in in the
humanities necessarily to understand as
well as they should what it is they're
trying whether they just they're aiming
at this is the case of Pinker's
treatment of music and how the mind
works it's a shameful treatment of music
here ed Fred Laerdal and and and ray
jackendoff on the hierarchy structures
in music and he said oh I've got it all
now and that was it right and so he
dismisses it as piggybacking on language
and having no independent status if it's
of its own which I object to just
because I'm a musician and a
musicologist but I object also because
it seems to me that this is not the
phenomenon that I know as music right so
then you asked about the definition of
music and well I mean I've given you a
pretty good idea here as best I can
probably I'm not sure that I'm not sure
that I can sum it up in an in a phrase
or two it is capacious it is necessarily
capacious it is a sense of something
that is that probably has to do with
indexical science rather than symbols it
has to do with a kind of extraordinarily
complex Lee ordered set of indexical
signs and percepts that are produced
that are not carrying meaning the way
language does even though it then gets
surrounded in human behavior by language
and comes to carry all kinds of meanings
so music in music is is a very very
complex it's I think it's a unique human
feature to name something else that that
puts together in such a complex fashion
constructions out of non referential
signals and signs it's almost impossible
to do in human in human behavior it
seems to me
say again I didn't hear the question was
is there is there a threshold from non
music into music is there a
chronological I would say threshold from
non music into music I think there is a
co a momentous coalescence but I think
it's got to be over a very long span now
the other thing I will say in answer to
that is that the incremental the
incremental ISM of the account suggests
that when this that that there can be no
moment in which a group of behaviors is
coherently together and then shifts from
non music into music what you have to
have is components that coalesce at a
certain point and I think coalesce
together with language and coalesce
together with metaphysical perceptions
the imaginary realm all of these I think
are coalescing in human behavior and
human capacities at about the same time
out of these mechanisms these epicyclic
mechanisms that's the argument and it's
laid out in a greater detail in the book
as to how that how that might work but
in that there is a capacious view of
music in but there's no moment at which
non music in becomes music in not at
least unless a moment is thought of in a
very very broad terms you know if what
I've already I've already in a sense
said probably what I have to say and I
answer that the the question was are
there criterion criteria by which we
might say this is music but this is not
music yes I think there are I think they
have to do with things like a very
precise kind of entrainment of
individuals listening to other
individuals working with under
individuals that is not found in the
same fashion in language even though
entrainment of more general sorts is
hugely important in language a very
precise kind of entrainment on the one
hand a very precise kind of deployment
of this capacity to process and perceive
discrete pitch on the other hand and you
start putting these things together into
complex structures and that's the moment
at which it seems to me to happen I
don't know whether that's the threshold
you wanted but it's as close as I can
get right now
yeah yeah there's a question in the back
yes Michael oh okay I'm sure there are
many more questions but fortunately
we're about to have a reception and Gary
will join us next door in the common
room so each of you can ask some
questions but let me first thank you for
coming to our company of scholars
lectures this year thank Gary for a
splendid thought-provoking presentation
I invite you all to the reception and
then express my hope that my successor
next year will continue the company of
scholars lectures because they've been
so much fun thank you all